há o lado pessoal aqui quem fala é o dar
que seja muito bem vindo é mais um vídeo
e os trabalhos de que algo que eu não
sei exatamente o certo é que vai ser
alguns fósseis ontem se formaram no
twitter que o fight night at freddy's
trecho conhecido é que adu e é [ __ ] eu
tenho que chegar por mim mesmo porque eu
pensei que vocês não estavam a trabalhar
então eu fui investigar
eu fui ver o site fui ver esse time
neste encontro em um post um dos quatro
que ontem dizia que tinha sido saqueado
e que supostamente e adiar o jogo e
deixou 1 inês pulso destino que eu posso
deixar a imagem supostamente eram fight
night at freddy's 3 é que a de que
alguém tinha espalhado assim não possui
muito essa história mas foi algo assim
prometeu baixe esse jogo e na verdade eu
não fui aqui a depois hoje ou ontem à
noite ainda diz que não que não foi que
habitava apenas eletrolar então hoje eu
vou jogar lixo para que vocês vejam para
aqueles que não acompanharam esse troli
do nosso mix copcal também é por isso qo
por caraças e interagir com os fãs de
luan faz troca os fãs de frutal
mas vamos lá então o que interessa é
jogar aqui é o custo koff fez para
controlar os fãs o que estamos aqui
dentro do fight night at freddy's 3
supostamente e que a do ok vamos lá
então julgar ninguém
e pronto é estético 14 mário anos de paz
no haiti freire se vocês repararem o
corpo é feito com logo está no site do
oscot country ea cabeça do fred tico sta
brutal a este enganou muitos fãs
o objeto e supostamente é passar os
níveis de poeta mario mas está difícil
porque lá só caiana assalta exatamente o
que está sendo muito bem cuidada é um
golo do dragão
ontem consegui chegar até o nível 2 e
não passei porque eu queria fazer um
vídeo pra vocês que aí eu caí lá passar
esfregão e foi difícil eu a sério
ana correia sempre no último momento
ok as que conseguirem vou conseguir
precisa ganhar a taça só que é nível um
complexo pelo amigo eu não posso fechar
a questão para o nível 2
anda exatamente isso vai ficando mais
complicado e possui até que um dia eu
acho
olga sério e ontem uma música do troll
fundo ainda por ser mais irritante mil
este escola é tramado não evita
assaltado por não picuinhas
lá eu pratiquei manteiga nos pés
ae não eu acho que paguei meu tempo
faltar pois néné que consegui foi que é
nível 2 completo bom ou ou não conhecer
thiago não quiser
olha posso chegar e ficar esperando as
pérolas pela já percebi já possui ontem
a dreamhack outra vez mais um pouquinho
ontem esporte joão chuva que ir né
agora só tem exatamente não gosta do
dragão meu é mais rápido que eu não
consigo passar esta porcaria de nível
três anos lá
ok ok nem um golo do dragão não é o meu
só assisti furte pupilo lógica do fat
freddy's deve ver o que certos níveis 6
supostamente é isso faz sentido se for
assim eu caia boudreau exatamente e
vamos conseguir passar de 13 já não é
agora também consegui foi porque eu caí
nível quatro o nível 4 é impossível eu
não consegui passar por cristo congresso
60 vida já não a cair este ficção
traumática em meu concentração em um
buraco em buraco e eu não sei como é que
passada que o dragão poucos que
conseguirem nível quatro e não cinco
agora só vou deixar um link de inscrição
para vocês baixarem se ela ainda existe
mas acho que sim acho que os cortes não
apagou aquilo eu vou deixar o ímpeto
assis baixio e tentei passar este jogo
não consegui apanhar aqui porque o
paçoca meu
aquilo é uma taça falsa eu não posso
passar a linha tem que saltar ela direto
não vou cair em outra vez casa em salta
isso dentro não podem falar sério que os
pixels spixii um belo e chávez ainda não
cair agora não eu sou sempre depois do
tempo porque 50 e talvez eu não posso e
não posso continuar aprendendo assim lá
isso bem jogado
o cadoca dunga só isso nível anda lá
supostamente esta última noite a não
ainda há 7 mil na sétima se é que isso
vai seguir a lógica das noites meu está
muito difícil sair não
esta música irrita tanto a não dar meu
sério esta música irrita muito
não é meu eu tenho catálogo
instantaneamente é tipo por é tipo por é
exatamente como eu consigo eu sugiro que
o pico luanda a equação esquece que era
para salvar ela ia lá e isso está de bem
a calhar que agora preparada para saltar
em dia também de tim cook falou que o
time viveu pouco agora bolas de fogo
anda cá só podia ser ou só por dinheiro
era demasiado fácil lá naquela casa dos
pixels pensava que poderia tocha mas não
é o caso da moça vai ter beijado nível 8
seguir embora tal com 41 vidas a cair
tem que apanhar aqui o time certo se não
morreu ao cair com calma dar três pra
que as obras focarão isso as altas ondas
ruggle um dragão aqui é fácil é só eu te
amar e se eu cair nível novo homem foi
embora
está ficando difícil
não rolou
não não não tem aquela visava que de um
buraco aqui o aviso eu é que não falta
de tempo não lá lá no curso de nível 10
pronto está num passo na minha lógica de
sete noites no final a 10 noites antes
já não está aqui na minha lógica mas
pronto não não não eu vou bater ali eu
tenho que apanhar o cério tem de apanhar
o time certo tamanho la a sério ro neodi
precisa estar ali pra cima fred e fred
faz o que mais faz favor
o gol deles despistou muito difíceis e
isso dá em julgado
os beijos jogado nível uso o meu foco
não está impossível agora isto tá
impulso fel agora a não não é que de
qualquer maneira a campanha qualquer
maneira é muito difícil eu tinha passado
mas nenhuma é impossível uma bola de
fogo
o jogador tem 15 em 15 dias ela freio do
confiança em nível dos porque estava
muito vai como foi que embora que
buracos até isso o que não é correto
petrol meus habitará espera anda só isso
já que o usuário já que assim que ele
virá com um pico
isto é pior do que médio não esquecer
outra vez meu ver aquela coisa amarela a
brilhar eu penso é lidar que tu tens que
ir mas não tem três vidas 32 por de
quanto foi que eu dei um tempo expõe
essa que os povos foi entregue à avó e
os por aí que o matava tipo já não sai
da minha pontuação final foi de 3 mil só
lá vou deixar uma empresa inscrição
baixem este jogo e digam quanto vocês
conseguiram fazer conseguiram fazer mais
conseguiram fazer - digam aí é eu
consegui chegar até o nível dos acho eu
por isso acho que já é bom já sabem
pessoal com o vosso apoio
lac favorito fiquem bem até a próxima